hey youtubers is charlie this is going
to be my Justice League video they just
explained a whole bunch of stuff about
the movie and is actually pretty
exciting and is based on a comic book
story but they didn't reveal which comic
book story the biggest thing starting
with dark side because everybody's like
well apocalypse New Gods dark side is
the ultimate threat he's not going to be
the big bad of this first Justice League
film when we saw this deleted scene of
Lex Luthor learning about mother boxes
from someone that looked like
Steppenwolf everyone's like this is
probably Steppenwolf they confirmed that
he will be the big bad of the new film
dark side will appear in a prologue we
know Zack Snyder likes to do prologues
before his movies I think my favorite
Zack Snyder prologue is still Watchmen
just because it plays like a really nice
silent film all by itself expect the
same type of treatment for justice
league except the prologue will tell the
story of dark sighs first war with earth
so in that prologue we actually learned
a little bit about it thirty thousand
years ago ancient man the Amazonians in
the Atlanteans fought off dark side and
then he's been gone ever since so the
reason Lex Luthor is seeing three mother
boxes here is because he is hearing this
prologue there were three mother boxes
left behind by dark side one that's red
one that's beige and one that's white
they were each left with the Atlanteans
the Amazonians and then the ancient man
but here's the official synopsis they
actually already released it fueled by
his restored faith in humanity and
inspired by Superman's selfless act
Bruce Wayne enlists the help of his
newfound a lie Diana Prince Wonder Woman
to face an even greater enemy together
Batman and Wonder Woman work quickly to
find and recruit a team of metahumans to
stand against this newly awakened threat
that new threat talking about
Steppenwolf the forces of apocalypse the
pair demons but despite the formation of
this unprecedented League of Heroes see
what they did there Batman Wonder Woman
Aquaman cyborg in the flash it may
already be too late to save the planet
from an assault of catastrophic
proportions now notice that Superman
isn't in there but he's part of the
Justice League he's getting invited to
the party his invitation has just been
lost in the mail it will probably arrive
by the end of the film I think we all
expect Superman to come back before the
second Justice League
so most of this first film you can kind
of see how this will play out they go
around they try to recruit the bad news
bears they put the team together if
their asses handed to them once or twice
till they rally Superman comes back boom
take stuff from wolf down until dark
side surfaces and says you are all
screwed boom Omega symbol so what about
the comic book story that Ben Affleck
was teasing that actually got me really
excited there are a number of big
justice league stories that involve dark
side and the new gods but I don't think
that it's based on dark side war because
that's two recent Geoff Johns would have
still been finishing that story when
they were writing the script for justice
league so I don't think that there's a
lot of dark side were in there probably
not going to see aunty monitor anytime
soon we might hear some Easter eggs for
the anti-life equation though but just
remember they did confirm that Batman V
Superman was inspired by the dark knight
returns no surprise there couple aspects
of the story but but really it was a
very different story from The Dark
Knight Returns so once we know a little
bit more about the plot for justice Lee
we can start making guesses about which
story it is but it'll still be
dramatically different from the comics
they were also hyping up the new Batman
film that Ben Affleck is writing and
directing with Geoff Johns so they said
that there's going to be a lot of that
this gets set up in Justice League the
set visit where they did all these
interviews and showed off the new
Batmobile here they were actually inside
the Gotham City Police Department I
think some people actually got to watch
a scene with Commissioner Gordon JK
Simmons is Commissioner Gordon so no
surprised are going to be spending a lot
of time in Gotham because Batman is the
person that's putting the Justice League
together so he takes lead he's like the
Walter Matthau of the bad news bears
like he has to put the team together but
wonder woman is still really big part of
it they actually said some really messed
up stuff about her costume I mean it's
really cool messed up stuff but it's
still pretty messed up they said the
reason why it's red like have you seen
wonder woman's costume you know there's
some red in it but when you look at the
pictures from the set of the Wonder
Woman movie all the Amazonians we're
very similar armor it's brown it's not
read at all they said the reason the
costume designer and the producers kind
of decided that the reason wonder
woman's costume started to turn red was
because of all the dried congealed blood
of the people that she had killed and
fought with so think about that while
you're eating your lunch but you have to
remember that in the context of the
Justice League Wonder Woman is a warrior
in a way that super may
and is not she's a sword-swinging shield
bashing warrior so of course she's gonna
get blood all over but I just love the
idea that her armor had been so stained
with blood that it had turned red and
she hadn't tried to replace it but they
also confirmed some stuff about Aquaman
storyline so they said part of the
action for Aquaman's character in this
film is the path to claiming the throne
of Atlantis as you know throne of
Atlantis was an animated movie that they
did you can actually rewatch it because
a lot of that will be happening in these
movies he'll be Aquaman when we see him
in the movie he has the Trident here we
saw during the footage during Batman V
Superman but Willem Dafoe is playing
volcko who's very important to him
retaking the throne he starts a war in
the comics that helps Aquaman reclaim
his throne so Willem Dafoe's character
is kind of a good person he's an ally of
Aquaman's but he also does some pretty
terrible things to bring about Aquaman's
new reign so he's pretty messed up and
it sounds totally perfect that Willem
Dafoe is playing him because all of the
people the Willem Dafoe plays are really
messed up even if they're not villains
Batman will be getting a whole bunch of
new toys he'll be beefing up his armor
and the Batmobile he'll be fighting
parademons so he kind of has to but in
the grand tradition of Batman toys he
will have some very cool toys that we
did not see a Batman V Superman the
other cool thing about Batman toys is
that Batman will help make the flash
suit Wayne Tech will be responsible for
upgrading the flash suit STAR Labs
obviously going to be very important to
that too but you have to pay for this
somehow Bruce Wayne being very rich
having many companies of course the
Justice League is going to be sponsored
by Wayne Tech and here's the cool thing
about the flashes introduction to the
movie it's very spider-man Civil War
esque as then he walks into his
apartment and has all this tech like all
the cool stuff that he's been playing
with and finds Batman sitting in his
chair waiting for him just like Peter
comes in to Aunt May's house and Tony
Stark just happens to be there talking
to her like oh my god WTF Batman is in
my apartment there haven't been any
pictures of it that have posted yet but
he was wearing his full costume in the
scenes that the people that went to the
set got to see so I wouldn't be
surprised if we do get a look at that
pretty soon so Batman even though he was
killing people being really crazy and
Batman V Superman is now on the path to
redemption so we're
I'm really going to see a version of the
character that's much closer to what you
remember when you think of Batman of the
comics someone who does not like guns
but will use them when press so
obviously if you're finding parademons
it's probably okay to use a gun but let
me know what you guys think about all
this stuff about justice league it
actually sounds really exciting but it
does sound like for most of the film
Superman will not be present neither
will dark side so you can imagine how
they keep both of those characters bench
because in this movie universe dark side
is the god of apocalypse Superman is the
new god of Earth but I am curious to see
they didn't say anything about the
actual new gods so we might see some new
gods in the film but I'm expecting it's
mostly going to be justice league versus
the forces of apocalypse a get hype it's
going to be awesome so I think there's a
DC giveaway going on right now so I
should actually named a new winner
congratulations Kylie o-ren you win a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so and get your contact
details that's just on the about page so
there's a bunch of flash TV show stuff
Grant Gustin was confirming all kinds of
flashpoint things so I'll do a video for
that next be sure to subscribe to get it
and I'll do a new round of the giveaway
whenever I post that too so a lot of
Awesome DC Comics stuff happening today
why you guys wait for me to post that
video you can click here to learn all
about Michael Keaton's villain in the
spider-man homecoming movie and you can
click here for my Game of Thrones finale
trailer video thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight